[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
violence conjugale le Sénat vote une
aide d'urgence aux victimes
en 2021 143 personnes sont décédées à la
suite de violences conjugales
ce sont majoritairement des femmes mais
cela peut aussi concerner des hommes
bien souvent l'argent est un obstacle
majeur au départ du domicile malgré
l'accumulation de violence pour y
remédier la sénatrice Valérie léthard a
présenté une proposition de loi créant
une aide universelle d'urgence pour les
victimes de violences conjugales
son texte a été adopté à l'unanimité par
le Sénat le 20 octobre afin de changer
la donne le texte prévoit de créer une
aide financière universelle destinée aux
victimes de violences au sein du couple
sous la forme d'un prêt accordé par les
Caisses d'Allocations Familiales
l'octroi de cette avance d'urgence
serait conditionnée à une ordonnance de
protection un dépôt de plainte ou encore
à un signalement adressé au procureur de
la République
l'officier ou l'agent recevant une
plainte pour violence conjugale devra
informer la victime de la possibilité de
recevoir cette avance le prêt serait
versé en trois mensualités dont la
première pourrait être débloquée sous
trois jours
sont remboursement sans intérêt serait
étalé dans le temps en fonction des
capacités financières de la victime la
CAF pourrait récupérer au nom des
victimes la somme avancée sur les
dommages et intérêts éventuellement
prononcés à l'encontre du conjoint
violent cette proposition de loi
d'origine sénatoriale est désormais
transmise à l'Assemblée nationale
pour en savoir plus consultez le billet
de l'espace presse
[Musique]